welcome back to new rock stars I'm Tommy  bechtold and we just got our first  glimpse of Modoc times two in the  quantumania trailer the first shot shows  him walking around with a pretty sick  crew of Cassie Scott and the kangman  himself the second picture of him  however shows him in his battle armor  now we gotta go back to that first image  because it's pretty exciting if you zoom  in this Loom Zoom isolate oh my God  that's Darren cross's music God dang he  doesn't even work here are we getting  yellow jacket as Modoc is this some sort  of Kang creation either way Corey stole  his cash in some MCU checks and that's  never a Bad Thing Ant-Man quantomania in  theaters February 17th Modoc will be  there I will be there will you be there